Traduttore: Aurora Cont
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Tanti anni fa gli uomini vivevano
o meglio sopravvivevano,
in villaggi isolati.
Il giorno seguiva la notte,
non c'era l'elettricità.
Le stagioni erano quelle che permettevano
l'agricoltura, sacrificavano agli dei
e auspicavano di avere un destino felice.
Le tre Parche decidevano i destini
della vita: la prima filava il filo,
la seconda ne decideva destini
e durata e la terza lo recideva.
Saccheggi, schiavitù, violenze
erano il modo in cui l'uomo
poteva arricchirsi sottraendo ad altri.
Questo era una cultura,
una vita stanziale, isolata,
sacrifici agli dèi, sfruttamento
e schiavitù.
Ma l'umanità è cambiata
grazie alla filosofia,
è cambiata perché qualcuno
ad un certo punto ha concepito
l'idea del nulla assoluto
da cui è venuto poi un concetto.
Questo concetto è lo zero,
il numero zero.
I mercanti arabi
che viaggiarono verso l'India
insieme alle spezie portarono il lavoro,
il pensiero, gli scritti di Brahmagupta,
un matematico indiano che,
intorno al 650 dopo Cristo,
introdusse lo zero nella matematica.
Se noi oggi diciamo “Sei uno zero”
per dire “Non vali nulla”,
in realtà zero vale tantissimo.
Questo numero sostituì
con la numerazione indo-araba
le lettere dei Romani e le limitazioni
che la numerazione per lettere ci dava.
Muhammad al-Khwarizmi,
in latino algoritmi,
è un matematico arabo
che nel IX secolo
fece l'algebra e le prime equazioni.
Voi vedete 01 algoritmi oggi,
il vostro telefono, le possibilità,
i computer vengono da lì,
attraverso i mercanti arabi
dall'India verso l'Europa,
che a volte pensa di essere
l'unica culla della civiltà.
Lorenzo Pisano, detto Fibonacci,
nel 1202 scrisse il Liber abaci,
che portò in Europa la divulgazione
della matematica degli arabi.
Questo perché aveva seguito
il padre Bonaccio,
Fibonacci sta per figlio di Bonaccio,
in Algeria, dove aveva scoperto
la matematica araba e lo zero.
Aveva scritto quest’ opera
che poi Federico II prese,
divulgò ulteriormente,
perché quest'opera, Liber abaci,
non parlava solo di matematica teorica;
parlava di applicazioni,
di come calcolare l'interesse,
di come fare le costruzioni
e 250 anni dopo, Benedetto Cotrugli,
scrisse l'arte della mercatura,
a cui io mi sono ispirato poi
per il mio libro prima citato:
“L'arte della startup”;
l'arte della mercatura
è il primo trattato
sull’arte del commercio.
Perché quest’arte del commercio
è importante?
Perché il commercio,
al contrario del saccheggio,
è mutualmente benefico per chi lo fa,
mercante e comporta il rischio,
i viaggi, tant'è che si ispirò
per questo libro al mercante
Cosimo de Medici che, come sapete,
ebbe un certo ruolo nello sviluppo
della cultura del Rinascimento.
Lo stesso Cotrugli scrisse poi
quindici anni dopo il De navigazione,
che è il primo trattato noto europeo
sulla navigazione.
Questo perché nel suo libro
dice che il mercante deve conoscere
le arti liberali, il quadrivio,
il trivio, ma deve avere anche
nozioni pratiche
e fra queste nozioni pratiche
anche la conoscenza della navigazione
per poter viaggiare,
per poter pensare i noli,
per sapere da dove vengono le merci
e come raggiungerle, i costi e rischi
che comporta questo,
quindi andare oltre l'ignoto.
Da questo Rinascimento, nel 1492,
la scoperta geografica,
il nuovo mondo di Colombo,
le scoperte artistiche e scientifiche
di Leonardo, la Gioconda viene terminata
nel 1506 e nel 1512 è Copernico
che fa una rivoluzione nella cosmografia.
Come vedete sono anni vicini
questo Rinascimento.
L'impresa e il mercante
sono al centro di questa rivoluzione
dell' andare oltre l'ignoto,
fra la scienza e la conoscenza,
fra il viaggiare, la volontà
che viene fuori dal destino
è la volontà di fare le cose e pensare
di essere fattori del proprio destino;
calcolare il rischio
e quindi poi l'assicurazione,
la mutualità, la possibilità
di fare le cose, perché il rischio
veniva diviso, la probabilità.
Tutto questo prima dello zero
non era possibile.
E quindi oggi, 2018, siamo nel paradiso
terrestre, sappiamo tutto,
abbiamo imparato tutto
e il Rinascimento è qua in mezzo a noi
e in tutta la nostra vita.
190 milioni di europei non sono
mai andati fuori
dai confini del proprio Paese.
Il 37 per cento in media, il 52 per cento
se parliamo dell'Italia solo,
non è mai uscito per andare
in un altro Paese.
Questa è una ricerca europea,
non lo so se poi la domanda
l'hanno fatta proprio bene,
qualcuno in realtà è andato
in vacanza a Cuba o a Sharm el Sheikh,
che non è parte dell'Unione europea
e quindi è andato fuori dal confine
del proprio Paese,
ma diciamo che è una
buona approssimazione.
Solo il 16 per cento degli italiani
va tutte le volte, tutti gli anni,
almeno una volta, in un altro Paese
europeo, quindi non abbiamo smesso
di essere del tutto isolati.
Ben 13 milioni di italiani
ogni anno si rivolgono a maghi
e fattucchiere per farsi predire
il futuro per un giro d'affari
stimato di 8 miliardi.
Ci sono stimati dati di una ricerca
su caporalato e agromafie,
400 mila persone sfruttate,
italiani e stranieri, per un giro
di 16 miliardi all'anno.
Dalla Nigeria, ma non solo,
ma il caso della Nigeria è particolare,
della mafia nigeriana con riti voodoo,
ci sono le schiave del sesso,
che ci sono perché c'è anche la domanda,
perché se non ci fosse la domanda,
l'offerta non ci sarebbe,
che vengono sfruttate lungo le strade
e i saccheggi forse sono
meno spettacolari, meno violenti
di quelli del passato,
ma ci sono sempre, perché Madoff
con lo schema Ponzi e la Parmalat
o altri casi come quelli di Euribor
o di varie banche, ci dicono
che i saccheggi non sono terminati,
quindi ancora vita isolata, credenze,
sfruttamento schiavitù e violenza.
Ma non è finita qua, noi siamo gli eredi
di cultura, bellezza, conoscenze.
Possiamo oggi spostarci facilmente,
anche a basso costo,
ma possiamo anche andare oltre i confini
della terra, verso l'ignoto
e quella è un'immagine della sonda
appena atterrata su Marte, incredibile!
France Johansson ha scritto un libro,
Effetto Medici, in cui dice
che la novità, le innovazioni
nascono dall'intersezione
fra culture liberali
e culture scientifiche,
fra artisti e scienziati e ha chiamato
questo effetto “Medici”
perché era nella Firenze dei Medici,
che questo per la prima volta
nel Rinascimento è veramente avvenuto,
questa intersezione,
questa contaminazione dei saperi.
Quindi abbiamo davanti a noi
grandi possibilità, grandi sfide,
questo è un quadro di Rembrandt,
che ci pongono davanti la possibilità
di fare un nuovo Rinascimento
ed è l'imprenditore che,
prendendo dei rischi,
perché impresa e impresa
usano la stessa parola
ma è come fare l'impresa
e creare un'impresa
cioè un'attività commerciale.
Prendere rischi:
chi lavora con onore prende dei rischi,
ci mette la faccia,
non è uno sfruttatore,
non è uno speculatore
e quindi mi viene da citare
un grande italiano, Adriano Olivetti,
e vorrei leggervi
una piccola parte di un suo libro.
Dice Adriano Olivetti: “Attraverso
il rigoroso rispetto della cultura
a tutti i livelli della vita di fabbrica,
noi abbiamo favorito
il risplendere dei valori spirituali
la testimonianza della bellezza,
il calore della tolleranza,
la limpida supremazia della scienza”
e Adriano poi diceva,
sempre citando suo padre Camillo
“La verità risplende solo nei fatti,
non nelle parole”.
Io credo che questo sia
un grande esempio
ancora fruibile
e mettibile in pratica.
Quindi è il momento di lasciare
gli ormeggi, di non avere paura,
di andare verso degli ignoti,
di affrontarli insieme
ai nuovi imprenditori
e fare la propria parte,
perché la grandezza sta nel provarci,
sta nella lotta, sta nell'iniziare
qualcosa che non finisce con noi
e quindi il mio auspicio è:
“Abbiate coraggio,
andate e abbracciate il mondo”.
Grazie.
[applausi]